one two
three
four
one two three four one two three four
one two
three
four one two three four one two three
four
one
two
three
four
one two three four
one two three
four one two
three
four one two three
four one
two
three
four one two three four
one two
three four
one two three four
one two three four hello hi
welcome
to five nights at freddy's 3. sorry
welcome back
to five nights at freddy's this is five
nights at freddy's 3.
probably
i would consider this to be
it's not bad i don't want to go into
this with negativity that's not what i
want to do because i don't want to be
about it i think when i went into this
before
i wasn't appreciating it for what it was
because i was so enamored with like five
nights at freddy's one and two and i was
expecting the mechanics of those games
so i wasn't ready to
be
immersed in this new
game and i think a lot of people might
have been in the same way again it's not
bad i'm not going into this trying to
[ __ ] on this game because in reality
i think it was very interesting what it
was trying to do with the whole idea
that you only had one animatronic coming
after you
and your death was determined on keeping
this particular animatronic away and
also just because of how important
springtrap is in relation to all the
other characters and all the other
facets of the
lore of five nights at freddy's
so as we do this know
that i'm going into this with an open
mind
and i'm going to
really learn the mechanics because i
think that no matter what the last time
that i was really playing this which is
way back when
i never really learned the mechanics too
well i never really knew how to get
springtrap to move i had like a rough
idea i was trying to you know use the
sound cues and whatnot but
now it's time to try it for realsies for
realsies and i
i know what you're thinking
dissolves to cruel ploy to promote the
trailer for in space with markiplier
how dare you
how dare how dare you could you
how could you dare
how could you dare
how dare could you just because there's
a link to the trailer of in space with
markiplier down in the description
that's clickable upon any moment to see
an incredible trailer for a show that is
coming out on april 4th which is a
monday
the fact that you would think that i
would do that for you
just to do this
i'm insulted at the prospect i'm
insulted i'm insulted
i'm insulted
the idea that this is all just a
promotion
i shudder at the thought
i shudder i'm shuddering right now i'm
shuddering and weeping right now
anyway let's play this game
don't you dare insult me about the
link in the description i forgot to
replace it from last time that's all i
forgot i forgot
anyway fazbear fights the order of
attraction
right because this is in the future
well that's a sound
i am a listen to the calls again
hey glad you came back for another night
i promise it'll be a lot more
interesting this time we found some
great new relics over the weekend and
we're out tracking down a new lead right
now so uh let me just update you real
quick then you can get to work
like the attraction opens in like a week
so we have to make sure everything works
and nothing catches on fire
uh when the place opens people will come
in at the opposite end of the building
and work their way toward you and pass
you and help the exit
yeah you've officially become part of
the attraction you'll be starring as
a security guard
so not only will you be monitoring the
people on the camera as they pass
through you know to make sure no one
steals anything or makes out in the
corner but you'll also be a part of the
show it'll make it feel really authentic
i think uh now let me tell you about
what's new
we found another set of drawings always
knives and a foxy head which we think
could be authentic then again it might
just be another crappy cosplay and we
found a desk fan very old-school medal
though watch the fingers uh
right now the place is basically just
you know flashing lights and spooky
props but i honestly thought we'd have
more by now uh if we don't have
something really cool by next week so we
may have to suit you up in a furry suit
and make you walk around saying
but you know like i said we're trying to
track down a good lead right now the
some guy who helped design one of the
buildings says it was like an extra room
that got boarded up or something like
that so we're going to take a peek and
see what we can find
for now just get comfortable with the
new setup um you can check the security
cameras over to your right with the
click of that blue button uh you can
toggle between the hall cams and the
event cam
uh then over to your far left that you
can flip up your maintenance panel you
know use this to reboot any systems that
may go offline
so in trying to make the place feel
vintage we may have overdone it a bit
some of this equipment is barely
functional
yeah i wasn't joking about the fire
that's that's that's a real risk
the most important thing you want to
watch for is the ventilation look this
place will give you the spooks man and
if you let that ventilation go off live
then you'll start seeing some crazy
stuff man keep that air flowing okay
keep an eye on things and we'll try to
have something new for you tomorrow
night
[Music]
all right you got it buddy thank you
don't worry about me i'll be part of the
attraction i'll tell them boo anyway
i'll tell them boo every day okay so
this is uh i think this is one of the
first
five nights at freddy's games
that you
don't die
or you can't die off the get-go because
the only way to die in this game unless
there's some secret that i'm forgetting
about
is from springtrap everything else is a
hallucination right
isn't that the case is there any
hallucination that can kill you i've
forgotten pretty much everything about
this game so i don't know also i'm gonna
time how long it takes
one two
three
four
five six seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven twelve
third about 12 seconds versus 2
3
there
5
6
7
maybe a 6 7 i don't know so it's
probably like half as long to do one as
opposed to doing them all three i think
what i did before is i always tried to
reset all of them because i was like
hey there's got to be a thing there
also i never really understood the
mechanics behind
the sounds because sometimes it would be
like
he wouldn't move at all
what he i'm the best
here's why i'm the king everybody this
is why you gotta respect the crown
flawless victory i come back after so
many years still incredible still
incredible
oh god no
oh good god
i really did like they brought this back
and like really embracing the whole
follow me i've
shut up shut up you know you don't know
me
i'm fast
i'm fazzy fred pick
i'm pretty fat where did you come from
wait
buddha boo click
what is bbdbi
bbdbl click what is that
bbdb
i or l
i
no l
b b what is that
click b b d i l
click what is that
oh wait you guys get it says capital b
capital b lowercase d lowercase b l
click
balloon boy double click
ah
i don't know what that means what are
you talking about balloon boy double
click so double click on balloon boy
sure
okay
okay
don't worry i will
i will
yes i'm following you i thought i wasn't
i was trying not to and yet here i am
following you
not that i have much a choice in the
matter
you just let me on a circus path
you go eat your own ass and i'm gonna go
back over here because i was trying to
go somewhere else
i was trying to go elsewhere sir
i'm gonna go north
i don't think i've ever really
explored too much
okay that's parts and services
something about that
oh my god i looked away i legitimately
looked away right when that happened
well i'll never know what when happened
and
this just goes to show if you don't look
you don't know like if you don't look at
a trailer for a show that's coming out
april 4th
i have some awesome news for you
first of all we found some vintage audio
training gazettes dude these are like
prehistoric i think they were like
training tapes for like other employees
or something like that so about to like
have them playing like over the speakers
as people walk through the attraction
it would then make this feel legit man
but i have an even better surprise for
it and you're not gonna believe that we
found one
a real one
uh gotta go man uh
well look it's in there somewhere i'm
sure you'll see it okay i'll leave you
with some of this great audio that i
found talk to you later man
uh hello hello hello
uh welcome to your new career as a
performer slash entertainer for freddy
fazbear's pizza
these taste will provide you with much
needed information on how to handle
slash climb into slash climb out of
mascot costume right now we have two
specially designed systems that double
as both animatronic and zoom so please
pay close attention while learning how
to operate these suits such as accidents
slash injuries slash deaths flash
irreparable and grotesque naming can
occur
first we'll discuss how to operate the
mascots when they're in animatronic form
police of operations animatronics are
set to turn and walk towards sound easy
this is an easy and hands-free approach
to making sure the animatronics stay
where the children are for maximum
entertainment splash crowds and values
to change the animatronics to suit mode
insert and turn firmly to hand crank
provided by the manufacturer turning the
crank will recoil and compress the
animatronic parts around the sides of
the suit providing room to climb inside
please make sure the spring locks are
fast and tight to ensure the animatronic
devices remain fixed we will cover this
in more detail in tomorrow's session
remember to smile see what the face is
really fast
hello
okay
so clearly i don't know what the hell
i'm doing what is balloon boy double
click isn't this balloon boy i'm double
clicking i remember there was some kind
of a secret but i didn't actually figure
out what it was
wasn't really my department
hi well there he is
this oh
[Music]
huh
interesting
the law
uh yeah do that night over again
right okay so
i remember going through this and
getting the secrets but it's not like i
discovered any of them what's that hot
dog
what am i looking at there
i have no idea but either way
spring trap is in the house
which means that we got to be on our
toes
so there's probably like some kind of a
secret in all of those i think i got
killed by purple guy in the mini games
before i was ever able to actually do
anything
oh well alas
alas
hi
[Music]
can you come here
what was it what was the best room to
keep him in i don't really remember
probably room 8 is the best one to try
to keep them in anyway
and there's got to be a way to like
like preemptively do stuff i can't
remember if preemptive maintenance is a
thing or if you just maintain when you
maintain
so he was there
what happens when you play an audio when
he's already in the room because he's in
the room right now he's back there it's
hard to see him especially with live
stream probably not looking too good but
he's right there so if i play it again
he's right there but i think he was
about to leave let me try what happens
does he leave when hello you play it oh
audio error who the hell do you think
you are
that's a good question me thank you me
he explodes i don't know if that's true
i think he might be lying about that i
think he might be a bit of a liar
okay he's gone will he come back
he comes right back
see sometimes
does is that an indication of what room
he just came from
if he does that
so if you press it when he's already in
the room he leaves that is the thing
i think that's just a base mechanic
but if he's nearby
and i think he has to be
nearby
oh
i can't breathe
i can't breathe
but i think if he's nearby he'll go in
right
he must
the only problem that didn't scare me is
because balloon boy is a little [ __ ]
well that's not a good sound what is
happening
pardon me
what's going on
hello
hi
oh god
oh god
where is he
[Music]
also isn't it a thing that i should just
keep one of them sealed at all times
i don't remember how to play this at all
i don't remember how to play this at all
oh
hey oh that's problem
you probably couldn't see him because my
face was there but just trust me i died
i don't remember how or what i did wrong
probably because i was screaming in my
office too super loud
well
that's how you go and that's how we do
but that's why we got to keep going
always moving forward
always moving forward
or backwards depending on where i'm
calling them from
i think room eight must be the best
because then
[Music]
okay so he's in roommate can i draw him
into room five
i totally can't so he's in room five
right now so the general idea
[Music]
is
okay and now he's in room eight so
it does work
i just don't like it very much
that's the thing is it more efficient to
reboot all these are questions that i
have no answers to these are questions
that i would never be able to understand
so you will have to help me understand
room 10 sealed event
that makes sense room 10
seal the vent
ore
oh
hi
i see you
that that does make a lot of sense
that makes a lot of sense
that makes a you make sense
you make a lot of sense
uh oh i see him that's the other problem
i never really noticed him wherever he
was
so he's moving but the vent is sealed
so then if if i have him there maybe
preemptive maintenance is a thing
and i can actually get ahead of the game
you know what i mean get ahead of the
game you know what else is getting ahead
of the game watching the trailer for in
space with markiplier a fantastic show
with a fantastic crew made by a
fantastic person whoever made that must
be some kind of a genius
well or handsome
and or beautiful
take a pic
anyway it would be great if there was
like a convenient link in the
description to this trailer so that
people could watch it in all of its
glory whenever they wants to whenever
it's they wants to
it would be incredible
it would be astonishing
it would be outstanding
anyway link's in the description if you
mayhaps may wants to see it are you
still there he is still there
now he's gonna move i just did that
because i wanted to see for sure if
that's what happened
but the question is where did he go
oh
oh
oh my god i thought i sealed that
i thought i sealed that
i thought i sealed that
didn't i feel that does it not stay
sealed did i not seal that
all right
that is the interesting thing
it might also be a thing where if you
play the noise when he's in the room if
you play the noise
while he's in that room that you're
playing the noise of
he gets kind of pissed
[Music]
okay so that is now actually sealed
so he's right there what happens i just
want to see what he does
you you a [ __ ]
you a coward come kill me try to kill me
i dare you to kill me my breast is
exposed
i'm talking about my chest
talking about my torso
i
i i it is weird that i was just shouting
at springtrap about my breasts but i
meant my like in old shakespeare terms
you know right kill me in my breast
my breasts you know you know what you
know what i'm saying
this is making sense if it's not making
sense and it's on you not me what am i
doing
anyway springtrap
got something to show you wherever you
are i don't know where you went
i think he just gets real peeved
maybe it's a thing
maybe it's a thing where he no longer
listens to the cue
if you play it in his face maybe he gets
mad
maybe he doesn't like that very much
where the hell is he
come back here
well that doesn't sound good
hmm
come back here
well he's not coming back there must be
something wrong with the systems
[Music]
anyway
it's too late springtrap my breast is no
longer exposed you'll never find a
weakness there
try somewhere else
anyway oh god no
okay so that's the thing you gotta flip
away when balloon boys looking at you
but he's not here where is he
[Music]
hello
are you here
okay you're there i wonder if okay i'm
i'm thinking
that you can't get him to move
unless
you
play the noise in a room he is adjacent
to right so he's here
i wonder how far away this works
so like if i played it there
he would not move and that makes sense
why would he move
but if i played it say
here
oh god well that was a problem i think
he was there though right i think he was
so in that time
[Music]
i've got to figure out a way because i
remember when i was playing this i felt
like it was super inconsistent but that
seemed really consistent it seemed like
it was working maybe because i was too
stupid
that i couldn't see where he was
he's not there which means that he might
be
right outside my door could be very much
could be hello
so it's like as a safety precaution
yeah okay he's there now
but there any yeah there's one there
look at him here
and there he is he's in the back okay
i wonder because cam 10 is technically
in the adjacent room would it work
nah it doesn't work it has to be right
next to him okay i know this is all very
obvious to you
but i'm an idiot and i'm real dumb okay
there he is
he's over there he's in cam 9 now which
is good because cam 10 vent is blocked
up and if i get him over here audio air
i know it's not efficient to reboot all
but it it's like preventative
maintenance i noticed that the other
ones don't break as much as it did when
i was playing just a bit ago if i just
go ahead and reboot all of them why
would they give you the option why would
they give you the option just do it
every time little a little prevent
why i need to flip it
well preventative doesn't really do
anything if i'm doing that probably on
that one i should probably only do the
ventilation because then i'm i'm not
breathing obviously
and that's a problem and someone's
crawling around the vents and that's
also a problem
well bumps today all right
he got me
he got me probably because when that
happens i'm probably just like
oh and there's a vent right to my right
so it's just like a trumpet of breathing
shuttling down towards me
i got an event
yeah he got me everybody he got me he
got me
i would never play tricks on you like
that
so cruel
[Music]
hello
i feel like there's got to be a better i
mean i feel like that's probably the
strategy is just to do them
then 10 shove them in there
try to keep them in the back
is that what that's what it would be but
also it's dangerous because vent nine
vent nine seems to be a precocious
situation because vent nine kind of
leads straight to me
and that's a problem
that's a bit of an issue so if you can
keep him there why not keep him in
roommate
where is he
he's gone
he's disappeared is that him no that's
not him
i'm
i'm dead
i'm a dead man
i might be dead
where are you
there he is
roommate i'm telling you guys roommate
is where it's at all these old
strategies
they didn't count on our advances in
technology
which is what i got
i got a computer cranking this out at a
whopping 24 frames per second
this uh oh
i might be dead
hang on
hold hold hold where oh god that's
that's what you call bad
[Music]
uh oh
did i make it that probably didn't well
let's just go ahead and put this here
i'm probably dead i think i am dead i'm
probably dead
i don't know what i'm doing oh good
okay he's there which is interesting so
he was looking at my door
so go there now
where can you get him from
hither to tither oh god are you looking
at me right now
are you looking at me right now not
anymore i'm just going to reboot
everything profoundly and then you're
not going to be looking at me much
longer if you know what i'm saying
do you know what i'm saying
yeah i think you do
i think you do
well this is taking a while
oh oh that's not good oh my god
well i might be
oh
so how do you get him to move
i wonder if you do like cam
this one would he go he can't go back
into the vents right you can't put him
back in the vents once once the cat's
out of the bag
the bunny's out of the bag you can't
stuff the bunny back in the bag
is he looking at me right now is he
he's looking at me right now isn't he
hey you want to look at that
hello oh you're not
uh oh
skedios
hello peekaboo i just gotta reboot this
real quick don't mind me
oh hi
all right so
see that's the thing right that's the
thing
it's the thing right
i i there's a way
there's a way i keep looking over thank
you mods by the way for posting a link
to the space trailer but as you might
have known and i think a lot of people
have noticed by now the url for in space
with markiplier is so special i did not
choose that it's randomly assigned
but right at the end of the url it says
come and so every time i look over at
chat i just see [ __ ] in capital letters
and i'm like what is chat talking about
oh yeah that's me that's my bad right
i'm wondering
i'm wondering i'm wondering if the
better strategy is to keep them over in
cam
three or four wouldn't that be the best
strategy
would that not be the best strategy
would would would it not
oh there you are see sometimes i don't
see him i got to check the spots
okay if i call him here he's going to go
over here
and then if i just keep oh did he
he must have he must so then if i slam
him over to three
he ain't gonna know there he is and then
i keep him over in four and then he
can't escape
if he don't come back for four
oh
[Applause]
what
what
fun man that's bad
that's bad
oh god uh listen hey buddy you gotta go
over here
older you're a horse
you're a horse hold it tight
how old it
hold the horse
i don't remember having this much
trouble last time i played it
i really don't remember
i don't remember at all
well i'm flying blind but by the judging
by the way the video went
i'm assuming that it's fine
go hither
he did
he took the bait that dumb [ __ ]
he's so stupid and i'm so smart
yeah no
that url it's i swear it's not a virus
or anything or whatever i don't know is
he here i don't know get over here
there he is there he is there's our
there there
there's our boy
there's our boy come here are you damn
it
well shoot
oh my god i am big brain i am absolutely
big brain i'm not lying about that url
by the way uh you can go check it out
for yourself i i don't know how to lie
about that i know how to lie extremely
well as you guys know and never believe
but i do
i wonder if positionally where he is on
this
is an indication of where he's more
willing to go because he was kind of
leaning in this doorway before
so is his position in the mini-map
in any way relating to where
he might want to go
later down the road if you call him so
like if he's at the opposite end of the
hallway
that does have an effect
would that not make sense
would that not make sense
tell me it wouldn't you can't tell me it
wouldn't make sense
cause it would
so he's
not here
now he is here but he's on this side
so what if i i'm gonna do just to see if
i can
shovel him around
he comes here
very clearly he's on that side over
there
i could keep him in six
but why not bring him to eight
he's moving very nicely
he's moving lovingly
but i don't want him here i want him
here
and then i want him in four
[Music]
hello
oops well i'm in trouble
something like that something like that
something like that there's something
like that
okay
this is this is oddly much more
stressful than i remember i don't know
where he is at the moment that's a bad
idea
oh boy
i might be dead
oh god
oh goodness gracious where did he go
huh
[Music]
it was balloon boy
but where did he go and why is it about
to be a bad day
all right
let's just test it
i shouldn't just randomly slam things
right okay he's back there he must have
been in four
that's interesting so if he's back there
let me see something
he would come here because it makes
sense he was close he could come here
because that's what he heard and that's
what he saw i'm about to die but that's
okay
i feel good about myself and my choices
that i've made
this is
i i think
i mean i never looked up like the
strategies of how to beat it clearly
but
this is why i need to reboot on all of
it i'm just going to reboot all from now
on this is what's going to kill me i
guarantee you that i would have been
fine if i hadn't done this exact move
that i'm doing right now i would have
been able to go home happy with a smile
on my face now i'm gonna die
spam
all right is he in two
he is in two let me bring him to four
there he is he's in four now so four is
interesting because four does give me
enough time to reboot all the systems
because he would have to move two rooms
to be able to get to me
which hopefully is not good and there's
no vents by it i think four
is the true he didn't even move
i think four
it's the best strategy of all because if
you're up at nine and ten he could kill
your ass two ways to sunday
i don't even know what that expression
means i don't know what half the
expressions mean that we use
all right let's see where we're going
anything here
peekaboo
i'm not going to follow you
i refuse
i refuse okay what is this
so this has got to be a clue now
four cupcakes
so was it a thing that i had to click on
all four cupcakes is that is that what
the thing is i feel like i feel like i
just wan i i watched a walkthrough or
something of it
follow me i will not
i will not follow you four
cupcakes that's bonnie who's bonnie i
have no idea who bonnie is
who's bonnie
oh you mean uh
you mean chica this is chica clearly
clearly obviously trust me i know
what i say goes around here and what i
say is you guys should listen to the
amazing new trailer linking in the
description of space with me oh my god
oh
oh god
i i've i i really do pride myself on
being able to promote things and that
time you know at that time
that was a bad one you don't have to
listen to any word i said because i did
not
i didn't promote it good so don't
listen to what i was saying
there's no link in the description
there's no space there's no trailer
don't worry about it
it's fine
all right where are you leading me buddy
i'm going this way
oh that just leads back there
all right fine time to die i suppose
hmm is that freddy
peculiar
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
let's listen
uh hello hello
uh for today's lesson we will be
continuing our training on proper
handling techniques with using an
animatronic as a system please ensure
that the animatronic parts are tightly
compressed and fastened by the spring
locks located around the inside of the
suit it may take a few moments to
position your head and torso between
these parts in a manner where you can
move and seat try not to nudge or press
against any of the spring locks inside
the tube do not touch the spring locks
at any time do not breathe on the spring
locks as moisture may loosen them and
cause them to break loose in the case
that the spring locks come loose while
you are wearing a suit please try to
maneuver away from populated areas
before bleeding out as to not ruin your
customer experience
as always if there is ever an emergency
please go to the designated space room
every location
[Music]
[Music]
face of pretty fast parenting
[Music]
uh oh that's oh my god hi bro
hey bud
hey
hello my baby
hello all right
okay
hang on i'm finding a cupcake
i can handle it
i can handle a little wooz
little ooze where's that last cupcake
where's that deliciousness
oh
hey you're my cupcake all right uh so
all right
so what i need to do is there are
cupcakes i did not know that oh sorry
the volume was very loud
i apologize
i apologize
i don't apologize for anything you
should apologize to me for not having
ears strong enough to sustain the volume
of my stream somehow it's your fault
all right where's this last cupcake i
got three here
oh that was old
oh i thought she had a gun i literally
thought that was a gun
chica's rampage
is this the shotgun of 87.
[Music]
wow chica look at her go
wow
oh
boink
there you go kids
[Music]
oh
anyway
[Music]
we are you crying
what are you some kind of a baby
these are big cakes
[Music]
oh exit
[Music]
oh right this was all for like the happy
ending wasn't there supposed to be like
a happy ending or something like that
wasn't that the whole deal
wasn't that something
i remember that as being something
where are you
hello ugly [ __ ]
[Music]
so you're there so one when you come
down here
and there you are okay good to see you
good to see you so you're there
i think that must have been what the
general objective was right the general
objective of this game
in particular
was to
[Music]
embrace the idea that was
uh kind of like brought up in the
previous two games which was that people
weren't looking at the cameras so this
one
requires that you look at the cameras
all over the place the whole concept is
about that so when you have
you have like
a game that is centered around looking
at the cameras he's gone he's here but
why was he there oh was he still on
three i just didn't see him well then
why didn't he go to four
why didn't he go to four
he's in three right there
because uh that was what i was even
saying when i was revisiting five nights
at freddy's 2 right is that it was a
tragedy that you had all of this
environment and you weren't looking at
any of it because since the game gets
harder really you're only supposed to
look at two places but i bet i wonder i
really wonder why
buddy
[Music]
i really wonder like what
like what is there
about this game
maybe actually it would be better to
keep it in five because even if he comes
over here i can kind of like catch him
in a loop
where did he go
come back
come back to me
well don't come back to me
oh god oh oh
well that ain't good
hello
i'm probably dead oh god why oh that's
not good that's what you call not good
i seem to be much worse at this game
than i remember being
and i don't really remember being good
at all
you hear you're not can you come over
here please oh i'm dead aren't i
well one can hope
one can hope
well this is a problem
hello
oh you're not there
strange
where are
you where is thou
well damn it
there thou is thou
oh my god okay
why did freddie attack i don't really
remember how any of the other ones
worked
i don't really remember
it's uh what it is about this game this
one in particular is that the direct
connection from action to result is not
as clear
as it has been in five nights at
freddy's one and two in five nights at
freddy's one and two the
inputs are so responsive everything you
do is so
obvious
that it makes it very hard for you to
not understand what you did wrong and
also
even in terms of like the actual
gameplay and preventative of you dying
let's say
it's still
pretty clear
at the end of the day
what you're doing
right in those two games in this one it
doesn't because it's all like tangential
mechanics you have the audio cue right
what does the audio cue really do
you know what i mean how does the audio
queue
move him you kind of have a general
understanding of it and you you you know
that you need to have him
get away from you
but you do an audioq and then a a second
later it kind of goes fuzzy and then a
few seconds later you kind of hunt
around like okay he's here i'm good this
is okay
as opposed to say for example
uh
in five nights at freddy's 2 flashlight
there click wind up you're good if you
didn't check the vent bat you didn't put
the mask down
you're dead like he was all very clear
of what you did even if you didn't know
it at first and you had to learn that
mechanic you still
got the general idea that
that was good
also i think i remember when i was
playing before i kind of stuck to uh
i thought i sealed that i think i stuck
him i tried to stick him in number seven
because
i felt like i was better equipped to be
able to do
that
i might be dying
very very soon
and so
that i think that's why this game out of
all of them feels the most off is
because it's not even just that it feels
off
it kind of legitimately is
different there's the mechanics of
looking at the cameras and like trying
to keep track of animatronics and and
that's all there it really is however
and i hesitate to say that something is
a core experience of five nights at
freddy's but i think cameras can safely
be considered
like the uh oh
oh god where is he
i heard that
i i heard that oh did he just pop out of
oh he just popped out of it didn't he
he just popped out of it didn't he
where is he
where are you
where are you
oh this is a problem
well i might be dead
i think i might be
dead oh boy that's a problem
it's like that fundamental connection
action and response
you know what i mean
like
action response i say
there's a trailer to in space with
markiplier that if you haven't seen it
you definitely should because the show
is coming out april 4th and your
response is
[Music]
holy crap that sounds amazing i'll go
watch it where's the link ah the link is
in the description below
you can find it in the description thank
you thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you very much it's almost 4
million views
very good
uh oh
i'm in trouble
i forgot you could just click the camera
again
but also i'm in trouble
i'm in trouble
oh oh
i thought he would go here you know you
know but maybe when he's made eyeball
contact with me maybe when he's maybe
when destined death is breathing down my
neck
i don't have much of a chance
i'm just gonna reboot everything you
know
i'm real bad at this god i'm bad at this
how did i get so bad at this
i swear i didn't used to be so bad
i think what it is
is
the way i always like to play games is i
like to play games either the most
flexibly or the most brute force
you know and they're kind of two sides
of the same coin
i think the truest true of the true
would be to have a general mental
picture of where he is at all times
right
so he's at five where could he go at
five he could go in this vent
i seal that off that way i know
that i'm good to check this because if
he doesn't go in that vent i'm not going
to die
and if i don't hear the vent then he
moves somewhere else and then i can know
that when i go back to the cameras
he's
not at five
so he's still at five
this is interesting i thought i sealed
that
it helps if i actually do the things
that i say
so he's there i don't necessarily need
to look at him
i wish i could hear him moving in the
hallway i don't think you can
can you
oh what do i do about that what do i do
about that
oh he went an event so he must have gone
in the five vent okay i heard that
what do i do about freddie here
i don't remember
oh god
he just climbed out of the vent i heard
that he just climbed out of the vent i
have to pay attention to those cues and
i think a lot of the game is about
creating noises that block you from
hearing those cues so if he went into
five
and he's not in the five vent
he would be here he's supposed to be
here
why is he not here
because he's here
but i closed that vent
how did you get there
how did he get there
[Music]
hello
i know he's looking at me
no he's not where is he
that doesn't make any sense right god
damn it and he's looking at me now isn't
he nope
what
i heard footsteps
there he is
goodbye
hello
whip
oh boy that's interesting well okay
i feel
look guys look you shush your faces you
shush your faces you know what you are
you are
guide look up people you are sheeple
i'm sorry i didn't mean that what you
are
is you go for the easiest route and you
don't even explore the possibilities
of what else was intended there is no
way there is no way this is a game that
was designed by
mr coffin
to be just played of shoving him in a
corner this is what i was always saying
about the five nights at freddy's games
and no one ever understood or respected
my opinion about it is that just because
there is the easiest way to cheese it
does not mean that that was the right
way to play sometimes dissecting the
actual mechanics of what is happening
and understanding it to the point where
you break the game
isn't fun
what is fun
is beating it psychologically getting in
springtrap's rotting brain
understanding
how to manipulate him
and counter him at every move you know
why because one is fear the other is
dominance right i want to dominate
springtrap i want to devastate his
entire being
i want to annihilate him psychologically
and physically i want him to know that
every time he looks at himself in the
mirror i was better at him at every turn
at every turn in every way i dominated
him
i absolutely
dominated him
and there was nothing nothing that he
could do to withstand my power
you know what i mean you guys understand
what i'm saying right you see how my
method is better and should be respected
more and deeper and harder than all
these other ones saying like you putting
me okay i'm not
i'll put him in the
it doesn't matter because you know why i
dominate
everything
[Music]
get out of there
get out of there
get out of there
get out of there
i'm also not joking about that
i legit this is legitimately a pet peeve
of mine is everyone that goes for the
cheesiest strategy because i feel like
that robs the intention of the game and
especially when i'm going back to this
game and revisiting it the last thing i
want to do is just be like oh let's beat
it no i'm trying to put myself in the
mindset of someone that's playing this
for the first time and going about in a
way that understand there is no
cheesy way to do it what was the
intention
what was the original core intention
behind it and how do you use that to
your advantage and are there new ideas
that people have not explored and how
better can i absolutely
dominate springtrap in every way
in every way
you know what i mean i think we i think
we have a deeper understanding of each
other now
i think we have a deeper understanding
of each other
i think we might have the deepest
understanding of each other
that's what i always appreciated most
about our relationship you and i
as if we understand each other so
intimately
just like me and springtrap here
perfect
unmistakable understanding of one
another
pure
that's what it is
that's what it's always been
anyway there's a new trailer for space
with markiplier it's slightly different
than it was before so if you've seen it
before you gotta see it again
where is he
he's not here
he's back here okay
i have not heard anything about him
being in the vents
so if i pull him back to eight
there he is that was quick
so
see this is what i'm talking about and
then responding to threats that's what i
like most because
there's being preventative i don't
really like being preventative it it
kind of like feels like it lessens the
experience i like the counter punches
you know i like knowing that oh i see
your moves
i do that i've been playing a lot of
eldridge like that
oh oh he's an event which vent is he in
he's in this vent seal it right he's
mobile i've got to be mobile as well
what that didn't work out so good for
you there did it
does it loser
you're a loser a loser
you get what i'm saying everybody you
understand what i mean anyway links in
the description you guys should check it
out i think you'll like it
it's going to be a good show april 4th
it comes out come back to my channel on
the 4th of april if you never come back
at all
i think you'll see something you like
i think eight actually might be the best
strategy because odds are from eight he
can't go too far
and he does tend to come back to eight
what do i do about
mr freddie man
what do i do about the fred mann
what am i supposed to do about the fred
man
i forget what i'm supposed to do about
the fred man
i have no idea
where are you sir there you are get back
here
just keep your camera up
nah don't seem right
i don't think you know what you're
talking about that doesn't seem right
i wonder if he never goes in a vent
that's closed right
i don't think he does that
does he go an event that's closed
i have no idea
i should do preventative but i'm waiting
for him to move
oh never mind see
[Music]
to me that was more interesting
and i think you know the reason why
whoa
hello
so what is the easter egg for this one
no i shouldn't
you see
i think you guys are starting to
understand why but no all jokes aside i
legitimately do try to approach games
that way three nine five oh i remember
this three nine five two four eight
three okay
three
ninety five
two four eight perfectly memory three
nine five two four eight got it perfect
three nine five two four eight
three nine five two four eight
three nine five two four eight
three nine five two four eight three
nine five two four eight three five nine
four two eight three eight nine five
four two
three i've forgotten now i've actually
thrown myself off three four two eight
five nine
three five nine four eight two three two
four
nine five eight
eight
two five nine four three
got it perfectly
perfect every time
did i confuse you
error
er
three two five four eight nine
five nine four two three eight
well i can't go that way apparently
ow
and i think i know what that is i think
i think i remember this one i think i do
remember this one all right everyone put
it in your brain right
now the
uh
call
hello hello
uh
slight change of company policy
concerning the use of the suit
um don't after learning of an
unfortunate incident at the sister
location involving multiple and
simultaneous spring-locked failures the
company has seen systems temporarily
unfit for employees
safety is top priority and free fast
fair's pizza which is why the classic
students are being retired to an
appropriate location while being looked
at by our technicians
until replacements arrive you will be
expected to wear the temporary costumes
provided to you keep in mind that they
were found on very short notice so
questions about appropriateness
relevance should be deflected
i
[Music]
did i just hear footsteps i can't
remember
if that was just something in the
recording or if i thought i heard his
footy steps
which is interesting because i've never
oh god
because i've never heard
his footy steps i don't think that's a
that's something about this game is like
i really well that's problem
oh
hello
hi
i don't remember you hey hello hey
hey hey
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
i forget what is it that i need to do to
avoid that i've completely forgotten
where i don't know ah there you are
that's very handy thank you um
so yeah generally flipping around the
camera will
no that's not good did you go on the
vents
nope
well come back
well damn it
hello my baby
this game is a lot more stressful than i
remember and i i do kind of like it more
than i think i did back when i first
played it because there are a lot of
moving pieces and there's like both
fast-paced timing and like slow timing
things that you have to nail down
with this guy you know
maybe i should just keep this locked off
because that is really a death
hello
he's there
and i do think preventative maintenance
fixes the random errors that you get it
doesn't fix the incidental errors which
are things that you should fix
individually i think that is the rule
you should routinely do a reboot all
when you get him he just won an event
which vent did he go in
i heard that hi
i wish it wasn't double click to seal
beat you
feature a [ __ ] to a pulp
to a pope i say
to a goddamn pulp
why does no one ever like my messages in
elder ring i re i put some really funny
ones out there i feel like i'm hilarious
and no one
votes up my messages in elden ring
god i love elden ring
god i love elton ring
anyway sorry i just had to go on a rant
there why does no one vote on my
messages
i just don't understand
oh yeah three nine five two four eight
i'll go ahead and do that now i think
it's it's like this um
it's this grid on the wall right isn't
it
i'm about to win so what it's uh this
one right three no oh god
[Applause]
hold on i can work on the pressure okay
what is it this is the grid okay three
nine five two
four eight
hey
well
well time to go crowd surfer
he's just flattened wow my hand just got
freaking annihilated
he just pops like cherry bombs
damn
bam
was that the stomp of 82
anyway
[Music]
was that the smooch of 74
wham was that the wall slam of 1928
[Music]
anyway
what do i do here i've completely
forgotten
well
looks like uh
we've uh
beaten the game everybody looks like we
beat the game
well
actually i i didn't have time to play
through the whole one today i actually
do have to leave now uh i've i i never
intended to play the whole game on this
one i don't want to set a present with
five nights at freddy's too i was
enjoying myself with that one and i'm
kind of enjoying myself on this one
um but i will say
in retrospect i think that this one
because i remember how it was received i
think it was i think it deserved more i
do like what's going on here but it's
always the thing with video games people
get into these loops they get into the
meta of it and they they just try to min
max it and they forget that the whole
point
is
the struggle is that's the point of
these things because then you accomplish
it's not about like trying to find oh
the cheesiest way the most efficient way
it's like beating my zone game i'm not
saying i'm
uh innocent of not doing that i do it
sometimes too but i have to shake myself
and remember like hey
it's a game it's supposed to be played
it's supposed to be supposed to lose you
know and alden ring has kind of been
reminding of that but yeah this isn't
about elden ring i love elvering but
this isn't about that
so yeah
i do like what is set up here and people
did really like springtrap as a
character afterwards for some reason
yeah anyway i have to leave but remember
in space with markiplier is coming out
april 4th
april 4th and guess what it's free you
guys deserve it you guys deserve it to
be free and so it's free for you
everything that we've poured our blood
sweat and tears into is free for you
just like all the [ __ ] i put on my
channel
and if you like ties you'll like this so
go check out the trailer
link is in the description thank you so
much for watching hope you have a
wonderful day thanks for tuning in to
another revisited i'm sure we'll be
playing five nights at freddy's 4 very
soon and then after that
one of my favorites
sister location
i'll see you soon probably sometime next
week we'll do this or maybe sooner
rather than later i know i haven't been
doing regular videos but because there's
a lot of work to be done before in space
with markiplier comes out
so stay tuned subscribe and be ready
okay goodbye
[Music]
link in this in there is a link link
link is in the description
do it
i'm still here do it
it's right down there
i haven't left yet
you know why because you're still here
and if you're still here you didn't
click the link in the description
why you gotta make this awkward man
why you gotta make it awkward
it's right down there
why are you still here
huh
i just you know
expect me to dance or something to
entertain you i'm done
i put in my time i put in my time
entertainment's done more entertainment
comes if you click the link in the
description but you're still here
are you enjoying this
you're sick you're sick you know
you disgust me
you disgust me
and you won't discuss me the moment you
click that link down there
but here you are
here you are still watching this you
know how i know you're still here
because
i'm still here
if i'm still here then you're still here
and that means there's like a space-time
continuum thing where you and all me
it's like a what are they saying quantum
physics is
it's entangled
it's entanglement
we're entangled
and so the moment that you look away
it's like schrodinger's markiplier the
moment you wake away i i cease to exist
but here we are
why don't you click the link huh
it's right there right there it's down
there
it's good video
it's right there
don't click the link in the down there
why would you do that
who knows what could happen you better
not it's dangerous
it's dangerous don't do it don't click
the link in the description why would
you who knows what could happen could be
viruses could be something nice but it's
not worth the risk right
yeah
yeah
yeah
don't
all right i'm gonna leave now i'm tired
all right bye